and he's totally like intoxicated like
blitzed right
the guy it was a very discombobulated
conversation but the point we knew that
this guy needed help right like here we
are to help this guy and so we're like
hey can we help you can we help clear
your driveway we got a skid steer we got
a team or another he's like nah dude
he's like i don't care he's like i'm
gonna burn this house down to the ground
he's like go help someone else and that
was his answer to us immediate answer to
us so we recognized like okay hope is
diminishing right right how do you find
comfort in the middle of calamity
find out on this episode of led live
[Music]
light exposing darkness
hey everybody welcome to led live today
we've got an exciting show for you we're
going to talk about that disaster that
just rolled through was it two or three
states yeah two or three states almost
200 miles of complete destruction
and um i have some awesome guests today
brockmire my brother he's been on the
show before and uh they have a really
neat ministry he is in the search and
rescue ministry uh whenever there's a
natural disaster they go in there with
with people and digs people out of all
this mess and stuff so i'm really
excited to have you guys on the show and
gordon here
got an opportunity to go on one of these
trips and you have a really unique
testimony i can't wait to hear this
because uh you know you've had a couple
storms in your life true and god has has
brought you through those storms and now
you've been able to bless other people
true thank you for coming on our show
so tell us a little bit brock about uh
uh gideon rescue and and uh give us a
little background of that ministry sure
uh you know we started in 2010 with the
earthquake in haiti and uh it's been
incredible to see just where god has
taken us from there but
one thing that we've really come to
understand um
is what god values most
and as this world seems to be falling
apart of the seams at every level what
god is most intently interested in
is people
and so what's amazing is that we've
really come to this understanding that
it's it's that spiritual rescue that is
most important not just the physical
rescue but the phys the spiritual rescue
as well and so we have tools we have
things that god has given us skill sets
that god has given us everything from
from paramedic nurse emt firefighters
you know people that have these amazing
skill sets that match the environment
but we have other people that don't have
those skill sets i'm thinking of your
cousin who's one of our key members uh
he's a mortgage broker you know
but he sees that like
there's such a need and he has a part to
play he has a piece that he can
contribute in reaching people in a very
critical time so
um
it's been it's been a development over
the years and one thing that we've
really just come to
understand that is so vital is this this
spiritual golden hour and we'll talk
about that further as we get into it but
so gordon tell us a little bit about
your background where did how did you
fit into this whole picture here um
so i'm a convert to the faith okay uh
myself uh around 2003. i've been in the
church for a while um happened to have
relocated to kentucky
um and had a friend who knew brock knew
the ministry was familiar with the
ministry gave me a call
and said hey man there's a whole team
out here gideon never heard of you guys
i said all right i'll check that out he
gave me brock's number gave him a call
and i'm on i was on the central almost
eastern side of kentucky i was about
four hours away so uh brock said yeah
man come on out we use all the help we
can and i took a drive first of all i
should probably introduce brad brad's
part of our team he just joined up when
uh you'll see a lot more of him on the
shows coming up in the future but uh
welcome brad thank you
and uh brad actually uh lived in the
same town as brock for a little while so
you guys have known each other for a
little while yeah
welcome to our side of the country right
right east side east coast huh but you
but you went to school over here right i
did yeah absolutely have you ever been
near a tornado or anything yes we had a
few roll through uh nashville at one
time and we also had a ice storm that
took out everything for weeks and so
that was that was fun but nothing like i
think what you're gonna describe today
yeah it's pretty pretty major yeah well
and that's the amazing thing is that the
storms that we're seeing
are just i mean everything is
unprecedented it's like we're smashing
all the records we're smashing all the
previous you know set you know storms
we've seen before are ready to get into
the why it's
yeah i mean you know jesus is coming
soon i mean that's the ultimate why yeah
um
but you know it's amazing i mean this
particular storm in itself and i just
have some i just have some quick
pictures so you guys can see the level
of destruction but you know this storm
was 304 miles an hour clocked on the
ground
now just to put that in comparison you
know um
we respond to any disasters and one of
the ones that is real common here in the
united states is hurricanes so category
5 hurricane is going to be anywhere from
about 150 to 180 miles an hour i mean
you know that's right
and that's sustained wind so granted
there are some differences here but at
the same time like
304 miles an hour is a completely
different ballpark and that's the max
that is highest yeah that's that's we're
off the charts now right like we're in
unchartered territory as far as wind
speed goes this is where they say blades
of grass turn into bullets right oh yeah
stuff's just flying around and and the
length of the structure i think the
previous record that was set in the
united states the longest known path of
destruction i think was in the early
1900s like 1920 or something and i think
it was
210 miles i think is what it was and i
think this one exceeded it for a single
tornado that they tracked
from arkansas through kentucky
i think it was
230 to 240 miles i think 300 and like 50
some odd miles of multiple storms all
together in that series because there
was more than one tornado so i mean you
know it was like three or four different
tornadoes and so the track of
destruction is just it's i mean yeah you
can't even describe it when this rolled
through uh chattanooga i mean granted
was like on a tiny scale compared to
this thing i remember that was the first
time i'd ever seen what that actually
looks like and it looks like a war zone
i mean you go in there and it's just
it's daunting where do you start in this
thing like how do you even i'm i'm
shocked more people don't die
like how is that possible so so that
that's that's the mira the miracle this
entire you know every time we go to
these disasters
is um you know when you look at this
kind of destruction you know you're
looking here and you're seeing like
total destruction in many cases i mean
wiped off the foundation and yet there's
all these miraculous stories of people
like there were people actually in that
building there were people actually in
that house and they were huddled in the
bathroom and they survived and
oftentimes without a scratch
you know some of them are injured and
they're in the hospitals and recovering
but what's amazing is that out of this
storm we probably should have seen
thousands of deaths and yet you know
unfortunately we did lose 100 plus you
know out of this storm but what's
incredible is that the death destruction
should have been more and so it's almost
like god's hand is just i mean like
really miraculously moving you know in
these storms like saying no you can
touch this house but you can't touch the
people in this house right i mean on a
few occasions we heard testimonies with
just that one room was left that the
individuals were in that's incredible
like those were the only walls standing
at least heard that at least more than
two or three times you know which is
incredible so when the chattanooga one
happened um we went out praying with
people and handing out literature and um
um there was a neighbor that was outside
of his house and he he started talking
with us and he said his next door
neighbor was an old lady
and um she woke up in the middle of the
night and she went to the bathroom she
was really old like 80 something years
old and the tornado rolled through and
took out half of her house and so the
neighbor you know after the everything
stopped went running outside to check on
his neighbor and you know oh my goodness
is she okay
and uh you know he looked at half of her
house gone he's calling out to her name
and all of a sudden she sticks her head
out of the bathroom and she said you
know i i woke up last night and i went
to the bathroom and all of a sudden my
whole bedroom went
like this and she had just gotten into
the bathroom and then the and then the
half of her house went away yeah so yeah
i know god's you know about his
protection absolutely nighttime
tornadoes are the most deadly tornadoes
um just because it's hard to have that
warning system in place if you're asleep
and you put your phone on airplane mode
do you want to be disturbed you know
like your neighbors aren't gonna be
calling you your friends are recalling
you so this was another nighttime
tornado and they can be really deadly um
but you know it's amazing god is god has
granted our group some incredible
resources this is actually a picture of
one of our search and rescue dogs um we
have uh i think we have five of these
now uh five canines these are highly
trained dogs that um god is just blessed
it's incredible this is a blessing that
we could have never afforded and each
one of these dogs is about seventy
thousand dollars worth of training that
they that they put into these dogs so
yeah um you know we have a five of them
most of our assets are tied up in our
dogs i guess
but but it's incredible these dogs have
this incredible um you know gift to to
be able to find humans in rubble but
even even with that gift you look at
this pile and you're thinking man like
how can they even you know where do you
start you know how can you even find
somebody in this mess um and so it's
it's been interesting but the dogs are
they're they're a tool they really open
up the door um as we're in these
communities because people see that you
know it's it's an asset that you know is
so desperately needed but one thing
this picture really is is um is
captivating to me because you look at
just the the humanity of the situation
right can you imagine if this was your
house you know you've lost everything
there's so many memories that are there
and it's like you don't even know where
to start where to begin and his his
expression tells it all i mean every
person you come across in these
neighborhoods this is what they're
they're going through it's just almost
like a dream state you're in this shock
mode
and uh this can't be happening yeah yeah
yeah
yeah and it's amazing you'll find you
know homeowners looking through the the
rubble and they'll just be picking out
like little things that are meaningful
to them right i mean she's holding like
a little bunch of probably fake flowers
you know and it's like you know
everything's gone and they're just
trying to find those things that that
mean something to them and so what we've
found in in this disaster environment is
that you know it it's the adage we keep
coming back to you know you can you can
go weeks you know without food
you know you can survive days without
water you know you can even hold your
breath for
a couple of minutes if you're good right
but the moment you give up hope
it's over it's all right and so like
what's so needed like in the hierarchy
of needs if you're if you were to look
at what is the most
needful um resource
that you could give a community that's
just been devastated or an individual
because you know these crisis when they
hit you know we're not just talking
about a community 340 miles of
destruction you know what if it's what
if it's your neighbor that just lost
their father you know right you know and
you know death is such a you know
incredible loss for people and so it's
incredible to be able to connect with
people on that level you know and give
them hope it really i think a disaster
like this really kind of sets
a priority in your life that you don't
care about your bmw you don't care about
your you know anything your money it's
like what what you all ultimately care
about is those loved ones those people
that you you you care about and i mean i
can imagine if you don't have that hope
that desperation of just like you know
everything i ever have had is gone and
so what's the point of going on from
this point you know and there's this
tick tock video i wish i could i think
oh yeah yeah we were there right yeah
yeah and then that with this guy right
and he's from kentucky i'm sure it went
viral yeah it was viral and he and he's
shown himself he's in the video and his
his house is behind him destroyed
and and he's i mean he's choking up he's
crying he's saying he's saying guys so i
haven't prayed in six years i said i
haven't prayed in six years but when
this storm rolled through last night i
was on my knees begging god lord save my
life right you know i mean like
this this is the moment where people
realize like you said it's like you know
six years life is speeding by you've got
this and that going on and you know
god's not really all that important and
then all of a sudden it's like in that
moment you recognize the lord save me
and and god does right like he steps in
so conclusion he was like i know i'm
only alive because i prayed right and
that was the culmination of his
realization like man i haven't prayed in
so long
and you know he still answered my prayer
and saved my life so yeah yeah it's
interesting how the same um
disaster
is having different experiences
though everyone's having kind of the
same experience being subjected to it
right
so you know for one person it's it's
life new life you know for another
person they're being put to sleep you
know so it's interesting dynamic
same tornado
yeah you know impacting people a little
differently yeah but yet the same yeah
yeah yeah it's the dynamics are
absolutely incredible so when you
connect with people on that level and
you hear their stories
i mean this is why that's why we love to
go to disaster because it just opens up
that conversation
for eternal topics you know like people
all of a sudden they're thinking not
about their stuff anymore because it's
gone you know they're thinking like okay
where are we headed you know like what's
left what's going on and so and when we
see disasters coming one right on top of
another i mean let's just let's just say
for instance what month was it when this
tornado rolled through
yeah december december december
it's like christmas yeah people yeah
we don't ever have tornadoes in the
south of that time you know just a week
before christmas yeah christmas
you know what we started this year 2021
with a with a
gnarly tornado in alabama
we ended the year with a gnarly tornado
in tennessee in kentucky arkansas
and tennessee yeah yeah yeah so people
are asking the questions they're saying
what's happening
you know and the world has a narrative
out there i mean don't get me wrong it's
going to be out there politically right
i mean like the world has an answer for
why the the world is on the fritz right
right but yet biblically speaking like
we have an incredible anchor and
incredible hope because jesus pointed
this out he said listen
before i come this is going to be the
situation the state of the world you're
going to see disaster upon disaster
you're going to see pestilence you're
going to see disease you're going to see
wars and rumors of wars he said this is
just the beginning of sorrows right yeah
so it's like so so there's a blessing
like you're saying there's a blessing in
these storms because they actually cause
us to think about those important things
right that we need to be internal right
some people probably
wish that something would come through
and wipe away all their distractions you
know what i mean like
i think that that if you if you can walk
away from an experience like this and
realign your life with god i don't think
anybody once you get to the end is ever
going to go man i wish that didn't
happen to you you know what i mean
sometimes you can have these tragic
terrible things but if it sets you off
in a in a direction toward jesus
then
you know i think you'll look back on
that and say i'm glad that god allowed
me to experience that
that's the amazing part about it you
know like when you see a picture this is
what our photographer grabbed this
picture of these men you know they're
not even really a part of our team
necessarily these are just men who are
bowing their heads in prayer you know
it's like they recognize the need like
around them the world is falling apart
and so they're driven to their their
knees in prayer right
i mean it's incredible to see um
and then you know we this is this is
another one of our young men who joined
um
these these storms change you
and this young man you know has been
changed by his encounter with with
coming to these storms and helping and
uh and they bring us you know he's he's
a tree climber by trade so he comes with
a whole skill set um and it's just
awesome because you know it doesn't
matter what skill set you have you can
be a contributor in these in these
storms so
i want to hang on that for a second
gordon what is it that you do for a
living um right now i'm currently in
full-time ministry nice so just just
starting uh had a life change so now i'm
in full-time ministry um go stand and
preach is kind of the front ministry
right now and uh beginning a 501c which
is that is under that umbrella of uh
how to live ministries so but yeah go
stand and preach is what i'm doing now
full time so so sometimes that preaching
is done with an action right correct
them on them you know that that maybe
sometimes it will be great louder than
absolute words at some point in time so
i think it's neat like anybody can be a
part of this i mean you mentioned uh is
it your cousin that that is the mortgage
broker yeah anyone can do it if you're
if you're an accountant and your life is
pretty boring call brock yeah uh he'll
uh put you to work and chris is up for
adventure all the time so he's like he's
like tell me what's going on now tell me
what i'm gonna go over to egypt you know
he's always going somewhere so yeah but
it's you know it's amazing because
people ask that question a lot you know
and i think this is where the paradigm
needs to shift for for a lot of us
unfortunately because we think like oh i
can't come to the disaster scene because
i don't know how to run a chainsaw you
know and it's like i don't know how to
do you know i don't want to be involved
in that dangerous you know work well
what's so incredible is the bible
actually gives us principles that we can
live by right so jesus says can you hand
somebody a cup of cold water in my name
like and you will in no wise lose your
reward in heaven right so like just the
act of handing somebody a glass of water
and serving someone else because they're
thirsty because they need
you know that help in that moment man
anybody can do that yeah you know a
small child can do that you just need
hands yeah you just need hands this
disaster that was in um chattanooga i i
was actually impressed at real quick
there was um easy ups that went up and
there was food stations and and like
restaurants and all sorts of people just
started
feeding everybody i mean we were walking
around there was people literally going
out as people were picking through stuff
and saying have you had a hot meal in a
while
have it i'll bring it to you i mean
that's a simple act right yeah yeah and
i won't forget we're up on this roof
cutting these trees just like this is uh
this is a picture of greg one of our
team members cutting this tree and i had
this whole conversation with these two
with these two brothers man like they it
was so cool they were they were kind of
over their heads and overwhelmed and in
the shock of it and so here we come with
a skid steer and a team and we cut this
tree out their house we help and
everything we get done and they were
just kind of like blown away and and one
of them made a comment they were like
he's like this is amazing he was like i
i've never seen people like care you
know like this much like all of a sudden
wow like and it was so cool was because
like socially
we probably would have never like hung
out right true and i told him i told him
this was like man i was like this is
what you know neighbors are for right
this is this is why we need to be
invested in helping each other because
then a lot of these differences that we
argue about like in politics and stuff
would disappear right right because it's
like all of a sudden you recognize like
man we're in this together and it
doesn't matter the color of your skin or
your creed or your philosophy or any of
these things that you know all of a
sudden all that melts away real quickly
when you recognize that we all need help
i can't tell you how many people there
that i ran into were just overwhelmed
by how far
the help was coming from
and that they hadn't been forgotten
about and i think that's important
because a lot of times a disaster like
that touches down and you could feel
forgotten
man like why is this happening to us
well you know we felt you could feel
alone and they were just so ecstatic
like you're from where you came from how
far oh man they know they cry man they
cry get you know cheering to your point
you know
and actually right dovetail right into
that i mean you know this was we were at
this point of distribution and we
stationed some of our team members at
this point of distribution they're
bringing all this food and all the cages
it's all coming in it's all going out
but we realized like man it can't go out
without giving people what they really
need right yeah connecting them
connecting them with a god who really
loves them right so so we we had this
little choke point where all these
people were leaving from the point of
distribution yeah and gordon got that's
where i first met gordon right yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah and so we started just
praying with people you know as they
were coming out and so i literally say
because i you know i could sit here i
have all these skill sets i have all
these certificates i've got all this
training like it could be a long list of
showing you like oh man i gotta do all
all this all the way through z until i
can do what you do and it's like no like
no no like literally one of the best
experiences i had was literally just
praying with people at their car window
saying can i pray with you that was
probably
can can i is there anything you want to
pray about right now and people just
start weeping
yeah because because they they just yeah
well yeah you know it's so i got
stationed at the distribution center um
and first of all to your point you you
can't even believe that so much help has
come together that people are banding
together yeah so they have this little
mall in there there's food there
clothing the things you don't even think
about like oh yeah yeah you need diapers
now because you don't have a house right
right like everything you own is gone
like
i'm not even thinking like this and so
here they are getting their supplies
and they're leaving and you know one of
the things i noticed is that a lot of
people that we
pulled them over gave them some hope you
know in a little pamphlet and then asked
to pray with them they didn't even
realize that they needed prayer um until
it's happening
and then they realized like i needed
that yeah like yeah because you're so
like okay i gotta go i gotta do this
gotta find this i need to find water no
you get your little to-do list and
someone pulls you to the side and says
man you need to pray could i pray for
you and they just break down brother
like just break down like
and you can tell that the spiritual
needs to be fed as well to your point
and i think um what a praise the lord
that god put it in your hearts as a
ministry to be there for that to handle
that right not just the physical need
but the spiritual need right the
emotional need that's happening there so
that's that's why i was experiencing so
much man people don't even realize that
they needed it it's just until it
happened a little taste of of of how god
is like reaching out and saying wait i'm
here for you i'm not here for you he's
doing that through the conduit of people
and so yeah in a hopeless situation i
mean that just confirmation that that oh
wow god is real he sent people to
minister in my time of need
pretty amazing yeah so
these are these are just little tracks
that we have that we carry with us i
mean that the titles are just so perfect
right hope and troubled times right like
what is jesus doing now when freedom
dies where is god when i'm hurting god's
last message right you know and what's
so incredible is i had this i had this
lady when we were there at the pod
and um she was helping direct traffic
and she was just there helping she's
serving right she had this smile on her
face she's so just friendly and warm
it's like oh man like this this lady
she's got to be a christian right you
know so i walk over to and i'm like hey
it's like i want to give you one of
these i think you're you know are you a
christian she goes no because i'm not a
christian and i kind of felt awkward and
i was like oh snap
back out of this
and uh she said something she said she
said um
she said no she said god and i are not
in good terms she haven't been for a
while and she said i don't think i don't
think he could love someone like me
and it was just that moment of like oh
my goodness like that's what you think
wow you know like that's what you know
like
we're here for this moment right like
here she is serving other people but it
you all these little interactions you
see and and so i i didn't push anything
on at the moment i just was praying my
mind like lord like how do i connect
with this this sweet lady you know
and lo and behold like
later that afternoon guess who pulls
through the line leaving after helping
at the deal and she sees that we're
praying with everybody
she pulls in with her car
and she says
would you pray with me oh and it was
like oh man you know just like breaks
your heart you know i'm like how can i
pray with you and she's and she's just
in tears she's just describing how she's
had just one hard knock after another
and her life has just been difficult and
she felt like god has abandoned her
doesn't care about her and it's like you
get in that moment you can say listen
like the fact that well i'm standing
here right now is because god loves you
it's because he cares for you
he would send us all the way from
oklahoma or michigan or california or
wherever it is that we come from because
in this moment right now he cares for
you and when you tell somebody like that
and they they actually feel the hand of
god now reaching down into their
situation like oh man like that she
melted and she was just absolutely in
tears she yeah and then i gave her that
and she took it she was excited um brock
you mentioned it's been a golden hour
yeah and one of the discussions we had
um so i'm there experiencing this for
the first time for myself and i'm
thinking
as christians
i mean this is such an opportunity a lot
of times we spend money on evangelism we
spend money on renting spaces and doing
all these things
and the people here are literally in
need and they're literally open i mean i
feel like every track i handed out
people were appreciative oh yeah you
know they're appreciative like yeah yeah
i need some of this i mean who knows
they probably have no reading material
maybe not a place to plug their phone in
you know um and so they were just very
very open
um and in need and it's nice to be there
to be the hands and the feet for the
lord in a very practical way you know
during that golden hour i mean just
imagine if you didn't say anything
you didn't
you know let the holy spirit just ask
that question and you you blurt that out
and you're probably like you know that
was a mistake you know but it wasn't
enough had you not said anything she
maybe would have continued on and
thought man god doesn't love me right so
right you know you don't you don't
realize where everybody's at you know
and and you know this is this is rock
bottom for a lot of people and right
there might be the perfect time to just
be like he knows what you're going
through
now gordon i know i know that you being
connected with this tragedy
was also a connection point for a
tragedy that you had gone through
absolutely even just recently absolutely
and god had led you to this point
absolutely you know absolutely so it was
interesting so here i am i find out i
hear about um what happened in western
kentucky wake up the next morning and
you know we got up went down into the
basement woke up thinking everything was
fine
and then i found out all the destruction
that happened so i'm seeing images like
this fly across the screen and i knew my
motivation for coming
was that i knew that someone's going to
wake up that morning not have a house
not have a job and not have a spouse
you know oh my goodness
one day that's going to be your morning
this morning and i just felt this
burden um
personally speaking because i lost my
wife of almost 20 years
i did she's she was 37 years old to
cancer back in march 23 23 of 2021.
so this is fresh in my mind and you know
you mourn you cope you're trying to and
this i just felt this burden of like you
know what someone's waking up
in a worse condition than myself
you know my wife died in the lord she
died as a christian i expect to see her
resurrection mourning uh she's asleep in
christ but i know there were those there
who didn't have that hope
and needed to be reminded of that
and i said you know it got to the point
i'm thinking lord it's not good for me
to be here i need to be over there right
this is a divine appointment over there
just someone that i can speak to that i
can let them know they're not alone in
their sufferings wow not alone in their
loss um so i counted it a privilege uh
to be able to get there to be able to
meet people on the ground who were
hurting and to be able to share that
testimony with them
and to encourage them in the lord and to
give them strength and it just really
was a good
a good coming together it was a you know
and sometimes you had to ask yourself
you know
what good thing can you draw from your
losses from your suffering and i thought
this was something very practical that i
could take my suffering my loss and be
able to pour into someone else and be
comfort and strength for someone else
who
now understands
you know who gets it and i get it and we
can connect
i think that's why the bible you know
jesus
went through all the things that we
could go through so that he could
comfort us right it's a core us and and
um you know he could be that that source
because he he could identify with us or
we could identify with him
and uh you know what a what a beautiful
thing that you didn't just walk away and
say you know what i'm going through my
own tragedy i just can't handle this
right now and and i don't want to be
around this i mean one of the best
things to do is to go how can i go bless
somebody else absolutely you know it was
really encouraging it really strengthens
you and just the pictures we saw
the disaster was immense i'm gonna be
honest i mean
hats off to those individuals that are
there and stayed through christmas who
are still living there because
it was a little discouraging yeah like
where do you begin where do you start
like are we even making a den are we yes
yes those i'm going like
you move the tree so what look around
you know you kind of think to yourself
but you know like like worker ants right
you know it'll it'll happen eventually
but to be there to your point earlier
just to hope that people need
the encouragement to get up and live
another day in that environment i think
it's key
you know it's key and so if if any part
of my life
uh
any suffering can be used to encourage
someone else then let it be
you know or so it's not for naught you
know so it's not for naught
you know turn it into something
beautiful mm-hmm that draws people to
christ rather than swallowing in your
why did this happen to me and you know
poor me you know yeah you know but what
a testimony because when people see that
that
that a true christian doesn't sorrow as
those who have no hope
right amen i mean like this this is this
is why there is power
in the gospel like activated in our
lives because when people look at that
and they say wait a minute this humanly
speaking this doesn't make sense right
like the rest of the world would be
pretty devastated for some time after a
personal tragedy yeah and they're going
to be devastated for a long time after a
community tragedy
and yet when you activate the gospel
it's a completely different narrative
sure that gives hope to the hopeless
and it's like that that's what's so
powerful about it strength to the weak
yeah you know there's nothing in me
there's nothing oh gordon no it was
strictly
drawing from that hope that we have
being comforted christ coming taking the
sting out of death
taking the stink i mean literally
i've had this experience jesus says
blessed are those who mourn for they
shall be comforted amen i've had that
literal experience
right it's not just text on the page
right like i the lord has come and
comforted me and so when you've been
comforted by him i just wanted to ensure
that others were going to be comforted
that i contributed somehow to bring them
the same comfort that i had been
receiving from god and praise the lord
for um
missions like gideon they
provided a conduit to get that done you
know what i mean uh a place to stay
somewhere to eat somewhere to kind of
you know
to have that organization and have it
coordinated so that we can be his hands
and feet and go
you know so praise the lord it all came
together i love it that you know you
think about the dynamics of this group
that's just dazed and confused at this
point right if you came in just straight
up preaching
they'd probably be like are you kidding
like i don't have time for this right
right but all of a sudden you're
stepping in you're helping them you're
ministering to their needs and they're
going why are you doing this right why
are you from way far away and you came
over here to you you don't even care
about you know like you're like
you don't know me yeah you don't know me
you don't know me love is an action verb
i'm just amazed by
the way the world portrays love is not
just you know it's lovey-dovey feelings
that we get and we we want to preach
this and do this and preaching is a good
part of it but the work that is involved
is the most important part
and when you do that people see
the love that's in you
and you can have a much more powerful
impact
through christ yeah definitely love
demonstrated yeah yeah yeah can i say
there's two there were two
you know um
people are having different experiences
right so cars come up and there's a
different attitude in the vehicles
uh you know some who didn't know they
needed they needed prayer others
um a little discouraged there was a
gentleman that i didn't get a chance to
speak to but was in uh earshot you know
he and his wife lost their
three-year-old child oh man
in this storm you know and he got prayed
for and spoken to and i'm like man who
who didn't need that he needed that at
that time like even if he didn't realize
it like brother you need somebody to
pray with you someone to talk to you to
let you get that off your chest to just
hear what you're saying right um and
then you know another vehicle pulls up
it's a husband and wife duel and they
are upbeat
clean
um and we're talking and he goes to me
the husband goes
man i said well you guys impacted by the
tornado at all he's like yeah i don't
even know where my house is but he
laughs oh wow and we're laughing what
happened and you know what he said he
says man we have our lives yeah
yeah yeah he realized real quick what
was important he's a we're alive brother
yeah you know um so just even to see
that dynamic unfolding amongst the
people uh those who are i guess seeing
it half full those who may be seen at
half empty uh those who are able to cope
you know and some who need a little bit
more help in coping so
it's just it was interesting to see
those different um just stories unfold
before you
now what about the dynamics of like a
fema or somebody else are they not
allowed to actually pray with people i
mean is there rules against that if
you're working for like the government
agencies no i don't i i don't know if
there's actual you know rules against
them i mean obviously we come from a
long tradition of separating church and
state so you know state entities don't
have a religious focus and they're not
going to take funds for that at least at
this point right
um and so there is some separation there
but um
a lot of people that are involved in
those agencies are praying men
themselves i mean we met the the the
fire chief for the town of mayfield and
man he was just in tears when we offered
to pray with him you know and and same
thing with the law enforcement same
thing with the national guard soldiers
you know it's like it didn't matter who
you came across like people recognize
the need for faith
it's just that for them to have that
focus
is not their calling it's not their duty
so you know they're very good at what
they do you know they come in with all
their organization all their structure
and their you know their heavy equipment
and all these things and so they're
professionals to the highest degree
but they're not professionals in the
spiritual sense not not not corporately
now individually there may be some
strong you know spiritual men or women
within those groups yeah but as so far
as corporately that's not their focus
nor should it be their focus
yeah but but this is why it's this is
why that gap is so essential is that
you've there's i mean we're never going
to be a fema team like that's not right
that's not our ambition right you know
like we're not going to come in like
fema and try to take care of the
situation but but we want to be able to
fill the gap where some of these other
entities can't and there's other
religious groups out there i mean
there's some you know speak to some
other great groups that are out there
and samaritan's purse has always done a
great job um and that's i think it's
billy graham's you know group that he
started um and um or at least was
affiliated with and and they actually i
really love what samaritan's purse they
actually give a bible out to every
single house that they minister to
they're like they're like here's the
word of god you know and they pray with
people and so it's like it's like yes
like this this they understand that
concept as well and they have their own
literature they give out to try to
encourage people with you know hope and
people need this you know um you know
this is a picture here corey um given i
think it's a great controversy and the
steps to christ to this guy and he was
just so grateful as corey just took a
tiny moment of his time like he's got
his work gloves on he's been clearing
trees but when he finds the right
opportunity he's like hey we have a gift
for you this is going to explain some of
the context for what you're observing
around here like this is the key is that
people struggle with context because
it's like when everything's gone and
we're seeing more and more disasters you
ask the question like what in the world
is going on what's going on that was
their context and now it's gone so what
is the bigger context yeah
exactly and that's what gives people
hope right if you give people context
you give them sure footing right and
then they have a foundation and then
it's like then they can weather the
storm
that is even gonna be bigger than this
storm right it's like we think like oh
you know this is bad
we haven't seen anything like it's going
to be much worse than this right you
know natural calamity is not going to
have anything when when when the winds
of strife are truly unleashed on this
planet and and it it's like that every
thought and intent of man's heart is
just evil continually right
now yeah continue yeah so so god's given
us like we need so people ask all the
time that i love when they ask this
question like well how do you guys get
all like this money you know like how do
you get all these resources right
resources it's amazing and i know i know
it sounds childish but we've really come
to believe this is that god owns the
cattle on a thousand hills
like he paves his streets with gold
right so when you want to talk to god
about money do you think it's ever an
issue no no it's never an issue right
like resource is untold and so this is
what's amazing is that whenever we show
up we don't even know what in fact we
don't even pray specifically anymore
because we don't know what it is that we
even need we're like lord you provide it
and it's amazing what god's provided
whether it be you know aircraft you know
helicopters airplanes uh even the
government's you know machines uh for
the work that's needed you've flown in
black hawk hello yeah helicopters
he's being humble guys
what he's saying is literally what has
happened
he's not just making stuff up like
examples this is what has happened
in august in august in um in the
earthquake in in haiti we had another
bad earthquake in haiti in august and
the coast guard actually flew our entire
team in to where they needed to be and
it was because of a spiritual golden
hour moment again because the commander
of the coast guard like sees our tiny
rag tag team there and he says he pulls
them aside and says hey can you guys can
you guys come and just pray with me and
it was like we didn't even know who we
were what we were doing and all of a
sudden this commander is saying hey can
you guys pray with me and so as he
unloads his burden he shared about this
colleague that he was just working with
they were running this whole operation
with this earthquake there his colleague
has a um a severe stroke they don't they
put him on a medevac flight back to
florida he dies on the operating table
wow
and now he's just like
man i need prayer you know like will you
guys pray with me and of course our team
immediately recognizes like this is a
divine appointment we're going to pray
with you they pray with them they
minister them they encourage them and
after they get done he says i've got all
these blackhawks sitting out here on the
tarmac like they're yours where do you
want to go right
so so so this is the amazing thing is
that if if the governments of men are
subject to the will of god
then the resources are never an issue
and so here we have the skid steer this
is not our skid steer this is another
gentleman actually um who actually is
one of our pilots who's who's been
connected with us um really awesome
story and and his plane was not
available because it was out for
maintenance so he was like well i'm just
going to come and bring my skid steer
can you guys use a skid center it's like
well sure you know so he shows up in the
skid steer
incredible incredible opportunity now i
have to say this about this gentleman
he is
a well-to-do
sports figure
we usually don't try to blow his name up
too much because you know he's famous
and we end up getting emails like in our
inbox where people want you know
memorabilia and sign this and that
source we just try to keep it on the dml
but i'm sure you can figure it out real
quick if you did some you know digging
um but what's amazing is that
he comes and i would say this this guy
you listen to this guy's story you see
how the hand of god has been leading in
his life up to this point when he's now
been connected with our group and it's
only i can i can say
clearly it's only the holy spirit that's
been like moving powerfully in this
guy's life and and just just the like
the fortitude and the character that he
has and the principles that he stood for
long before he ever met us you know
and and now what's so incredible is that
he's watching this all unfold right and
i'd say probably and he might admit this
i don't know like like that he's maybe a
bit of a soft agnostic right you know
he's like maybe maybe there's a god out
there but i don't really know how all
this works you know and so now he's
attached with this group that's like
praying and singing and you know
sharing all these things and he's kind
of like okay what's going on here so we
show up at this street this is mrs
gaither and we're in this community a
cambridge shores here and outside of
mayfield kentucky and um
mrs gaither lost her life in this storm
she was she was a little older i think
she was in her 70s or her 80s
she lost her life and um as we show up
in this in this area this is what you
see i mean it's just like hiroshima
nagasaki you know there's nothing
there's nothing left right you know here
our team shows up
at her property
and this this this woman here in the
picture her name is tassie and she is
mrs gaither's daughter
so tassie she comes to us and she says
listen
i know this sounds crazy
but
i would really appreciate if you guys
could help me find a couple of items she
had two items on her list one was a safe
with a bunch of documents in it like
legal will and property deeds and those
kinds of things
and then she said but the second and
most important item
is a is a a little red digital camera
and in that yes
talk about spiritual gold now right
people going through crisis right
her father had just died like maybe two
or three months prior so they just lost
her father right now that she just lost
her mother
and they have no pictures for the
funeral oh
right it means the world's a different
it means the world to him so she could
care less about anything else in the
house all right it's gone yeah but she
said she's if you guys could just find
this red camera and and this you know
sports dude that's with us is like a
camera you know like
did i hear you correctly you know like
yeah right like we'll look for the safe
maybe we can find the safe he's like the
camera there's no way we're finding this
camera right
so what he said exactly was well i'll
probably run it over before i find it
right yeah i'll write it up
before i see it i'll run it over first
that was his words yeah and so here we
we pray with her we're praying with him
like they're everybody's observing right
they're all watching this and it's like
the devil set us up for failure but god
set us up for success right the whole
dynamic there's this huge battle raging
right for this camera
and uh the guys are looking we have this
game plan we're like oh you know
everybody's pointing and searching okay
we got the skids we're gonna start here
we're gonna look and we're gonna you
know grid search these areas and
whatever and the skid steer starts
moving and it's and but i mean if you
look at these pictures it's like where
do you begin right we found a couple of
key items that were useful to them
family memories photo books um and so
here they are they're lifting up this
this section of a wall
and the guy they're standing next to
skis there's one of our firefighters as
they're lifting the section of the wall
underneath this wall
this tiny little black case
and the firefighter said hey what is
that picks it up
open unzips it
inside is a red camera
and and the guy that's running the skids
here you know our soft agnostic he's
like no way he's like no way
he's like that that's somebody else's
camera that is not this lady's camera
right you know yeah and we pull it over
there
and as we pull it over there uh one of
our guys gets his computer right and on
his computer is is is you know a little
slot to put the card in and everybody
with baited breath is waiting to see
like are there pictures on this card
song
350 pictures wow
after he said that even though he had
found it he was still saying like well
how do you know there's pictures on it
yeah yeah yeah i'm like why exactly
yeah they got to be water damaged
but we're all excited but we don't know
it and tassie she's here in the green
coat and it was it was like ugly weeping
like we literally had to catch her she
was falling to the ground
and and and when you connect people you
say it's because god cares amen it's
because god cares for you
he cares for you enough to bring you
your red camera when everything else is
destroyed because he loves you and he
loves your family i mean do people
people melt
and and and this guy watching like he's
like
this is amazing i've never seen anything
like this right like he's been a part of
like some of the most successful things
in the world and he's never seen
anything like this right
and he's like dude my heart is touched
this is amazing it's amazing can i say
this to you bring this up a lot of
people in this situation
are going to blame god
right they're going like that that's
right they blame the devil i've always
wondered this you just by default you
know he's the most powerful well it
hadn't been god for god sent this
tornado and destroyed our lives little
do they know i think about the scenario
of job where the curtains pull back and
satan is the one behind the disaster the
one behind the law so to your point
brock to piggyback when you when we come
and you show up and wear the hands and
feet showing this individual these
individuals that god cares about your
little red camera
in the midst of all this debris in the
midst of all this laws and tragedy this
begins to shift the thoughts like
man maybe god didn't yeah it wasn't
behind because if he cares about the
little red camera why would he destroy
and then help you you know so just for
the record
uh
giving this one to satan you know this
is the same testimony i had you know
upon you know losing my wife you know
with the memorial service and i made it
clear man the the devil's done this
has done this the enemy has done this
i'm not blaming god that's right right
he's in the business of saving life
that's right not taking life that's
right so this is a good reminder
and this is this is the conclusion that
job reaches right because he says though
you slay me go ahead i will trust you
amen right amen and and this is the i
mean job and god had this incredible
relationship that nothing was going to
tear them apart right just just like
paul says like no height no power no
principality is going to come between
you and the love that christ has for you
amen right so i mean like when you when
you share this with people and people
see the love of god because yeah you're
exactly right like when you look at this
destruction i guarantee you i i i can't
see behind the curtain but i will
guarantee you that what is happening is
that you have demonic agencies that are
literally ripping apart communities
houses taking life where they can take
life and god's angels and his hand is
over people situations red cameras on
saying you can't touch this right you
can't touch it further you can't touch
this right right and yet man like the
devil is angry
and and that's the only thing explain
like when you see this level destruction
you can see that man the devil is coming
down with great wrath for his time is
short yeah
yeah so um this community when you look
i mean just absolutely devastating i
just want to share this last little
story as we you know there's so many
stories we can share but for sure but
but one of these one of these stories
here we had the privilege of working
with two serve which is a
an academy here in tennessee and they
have an awesome program where they take
high school students and they deploy
them to the disaster zone and that's
crazy in itself because it's like you
know where you're taking a big risk
putting high school kids out there with
chainsaws and debris and you know all
this stuff but it's awesome because
these kids get this incredible
experience where they're out there
serving they're out there picking up
debris and it changes their whole life
and their perspective as they minister
to other people and and what's so
incredible is that they they get a
chance to see all of these miracles they
get to see god's you know handiwork even
in the disaster zone um this actually
this is a gentleman here i just have to
mention him honorably because um this is
a crazy story in itself
um
he was sitting on his couch okay this
guy not affiliated with a group at all
okay he's sitting on his couch i believe
he was in ohio ohio or
iowa or one of the northern states
illinois maybe illinois
he's sitting on his couch playing video
games
okay full-on involved in video games he
sees all the destruction of the
tornadoes and the holy spirit starts
speaking to him and says get up off that
couch
lay your controller down
go down to kentucky and he lays his
controller down and he gets up off the
couch and he gets in his truck and he
drives to kentucky and guess guess what
team he runs into our team we don't even
know this guy right
and so he's out here like with with
obviously he was handy with the chainsaw
he's out here cutting you know chainsaw
and everything just an incredible story
of how like god like just plucks up
another one and says no i need you here
at this moment right and and and this
guy is totally changed by service to
others right
he lays down what was controlling him at
the moment and he now starts taking
control of the situation through the
right and it's funny i have a similar
testimony we're at the distribution
center um an uh a pastor shows up
and it was so interesting the timing
like maybe three or four cards had just
come by where an individual had told me
i lost everything we've lost everything
we have nothing we lost everything
so this minister comes up and he has
these gift cards he wants to hand out
and he specifically says
i'm looking where i can find people who
have lost everything
and we tell them you just wait right
here for a few minutes yeah
there's one coming yes yeah the lord has
and so here he is not associated with
our group at all initially right
anything and he's there with us
just praying with folks now
handing out the gift cards getting it to
the people who've lost everything and
just how god was orchestrating that you
know uh that we could come together on
that level um to not be associated with
a person or with a group but guys i know
i know i'm gonna put you back i know
we're gonna go and i think he had gone
he had gone the wrong way and got
himself turned around and ended up where
we were you know wrong way right right
right you know so something got blocked
right there yeah he goes one pound
praise the lord just another you know no
another test one like that as well you
see all those i mean you know what's so
amazing when you see all these puzzle
pieces together if you see how god is
just orchestrating and leading
to to give people a final message of
hope
right i mean like we see this revelation
14 like god's final message of hope and
love to the world is mixed with mercy
but also one of judgment like we are
living in the judgment hour like time is
out like we don't we don't have any time
left so so
you know if you're convicted sitting on
your couch playing video games that now
is the time to get up and to start
serving the god of heaven rather than
yourself you better answer that call
because there may not be a second call
you know and so this this is what's
amazing is that we're seeing this is
that we're living in this critical
critical time where time is no more and
and and we're about at the close of
history here and god is activating
people right
um and so here we are at this house in
cambridge shores the the kids are
working on this house it's an awesome
experience for them to connect with this
homeowner and and and the way that we
got um it was amazing this was a whole
divine point how we ended up here and
the homeowner said hey will you guys go
over and check on our neighbor she's 80
some odd years old we don't know if
anybody's like she needs it more than we
do like please go over there so we go
over knock on her door she's not there
praise the lord like somebody actually
come and rescue her out of that
situation and took her to family
somewhere else so she was totally not
involved anymore
and um as we're sitting there kind of
surveying the landscape you look behind
her and you see like it's gone you know
there's not these behind this house
these are all multi-million dollar homes
by the way like these are huge
structures
and so here we're sitting here uh on
this otherwise picturesque you know lake
front and uh we see smoke coming out of
this chimney okay this next house i
think it's this next house yeah so this
set this little house here right smoke
coming on this chimney the driveway here
in front of us here you can see all
these logs just like a huge
jam of debris and they're smoking in
this room and my buddy who's with me
he's like hey he's like dude somebody's
home yeah come on like we should go
knock on that door and see if they're
okay if they need help you know so we go
downstairs we knock on the back door
and out stumbles this
guy
and he's totally like intoxicated like
blitzed right
but he's wearing like this like special
forces jackets got special forces
patches he's a green beret he served you
know uh afghanistan and iraq and um
the guy it was a very discombobulated
conversation but the point we knew that
this guy needed help right like here we
are to help this guy and so we're like
hey can we help you can we help clear
your driveway we got a skid steer we got
a team or another he's like nah dude
he's like i don't care he's like i'm
going to burn this house down to the
ground he's like go help someone else
and that was his answer to us immediate
answer to us so we recognized like okay
hope is diminishing right right so it's
like we're after it like all right lord
like please like give us an entrance
here and finally
he he gives us a little bit says sure
you can clear my driveway that's fine
whatever you know so we get to work
right the team comes down skid steer
gets to work it was a steep driveway our
our sports guy here driving his skid
there was really excited because he's
like in there tearing up trees and you
know feeling useful right he's getting
it done and uh and and clearing
everything out and then the kids were
next door with the neighbor like our our
kids from the academy and they're like
praying with the neighbor and they're
singing the neighbor and as soon as they
finish with him guess where they came
next
came right down to this property we're
working on right and so they surround
this guy he's in the middle his name is
reed right there in the middle
and they and we sing amazing grace
and
man it was the most powerful
experience ever
and this guy just melts i mean he's like
in tears right
that dude that i showed earlier that had
come off his couch playing video games
he's standing next to me i don't even
know the guy right we get done singing
and he says that was for me wow right
like now his his life has been like
dominoes man people are crying and our
lives are being impacted like all around
right you know and and and this is that
guy right here um right here kneeling in
the ground because in this moment he
wants to give his life to christ
you know it's just like when you're it's
just like oh it's amazing right even in
someone else's disaster
somebody else
right and he's just like man he's like i
i recognize that god is he's he's
tugging on my heart and i want to give
it to him and so like our two team
members here doug he's a pilot uh
incredible guy
a former marine um actually served in
the marine corps and uh and so he was so
cool is that on our team we had all of
these different people had different
experiences we had several previous
service members on the team one guy that
was a former pj a pair jumper you know
pair rescue jumper uh another guy that
was uh uh another former pj bruce um and
then um this guy here doug in the marine
corps and when they recognize that reed
the guy that we're singing to the house
that want to just burn his house down on
the ground
i told him said doug i said this is your
mission man go for it and he just like
takes off sits down starts talking to
you know like ministering to him we're
cleaning his house these two guys are
just connecting right on the fact that
they serve their country they have all
these experiences they're sharing and
it's just like you can see god moving in
such a powerful way and come to find out
you know this is the view looking out
off of reed's back deck here but come to
find out here's the last picture of us
all together reads in the middle here
um
reed
was given up like he'd totally give him
like before the storm hit like he was
telling doug our pilot he was like man
he's like
i was it was it i was i put a rope in my
tree i was gonna hang myself and that
was it wow and then here comes a storm
no tree no rope right whoa
so now so now he's in his house drinking
himself into oblivion right and that's
the moment in which we meet him come on
same storm same storm
rips a tree out someone can't lose their
life yeah another person loses their
life right yeah um i want to say
something about
just the importance and the influence
that you have in your youth
to be a witness for christ
i can remember back in new york city we
would go out with the young people we
would preach on the trains and i would
always remember how the people were
overwhelmed because of our age
and so this band of young people from
this academy were fierce man fierce i
mean aggressively going up to cars and
willing to pray for people and you could
just tell how they were being how
individuals were being impacted
by a young person praying for an adult
in their time of need
it was evident to me was very clear
even as he went and helped out a church
and you know it's funny in a part of
town where they were feeling neglected
that they weren't able to get the
resources that they needed
and the school was there already working
with this community and they sung again
there as well
and just
the witness
these young people had in that community
at that time was just
we'll probably only find out in heaven
honestly so far reaching we'll find out
in heaven
um so i just want to encourage young
people you know if they're watching
listening uh serve the lord in your
youth
serve the lord in your youth this is the
time when you can really be effective
and really be have a strong impact on
people's lives for
eternity that's right amen amen amen
yeah it's incredible to see the young
people at work
and uh you know jim ingersoll and
twoserve and heritage academy all those
guys it's just incredible to see the
work that they're doing with young
people we we always love having them
with us you know because it's it's a
weapon right it's like it's like it's
like when uh i think it's uh
solomon you know says that our youth are
arrows in the quiver david
they're arrows in the quiver it's like
what is an arrow for it's for aggressive
warfare like even advancing above the
front
front lines right up and over yeah right
so so we don't we don't take full
advantage of the potential of our youth
right so they're willing to serve too i
think so many young people in in church
settings
um a lot of times are willing but they
don't find a way to be used by the lord
so the enemy ends up using them mm-hmm
if that makes any sense and the enemy's
using them big time right we we've made
a ministry out of pointing out how
the young people
that's the point is that is that i've
often thought about this is that is that
here's the here's the real tragedy
is that hollywood and movies and video
games like the reason why they're so
powerful is because they tap into the
potential that young people have and
give them a mission and a message and a
vision right for the future and the
problem is is that is that the devil he
doesn't care like if you're sitting on
your couch wasting your time playing
video games like you're out you're out
of reality at that point when it's like
god actually wants you to live the movie
come on not watch the movie right
so this this is the real tragedies that
our young people have like the stories
that we've encountered and the things
that we see when we go on these
disasters dude they're all movies like
every single one of them it's one of the
best movies you've ever been in you see
all the creators you see comedy you see
romance you see you see adventure you
see action i mean it's like
and this is what
my appeal to young people is like don't
don't miss out on living the movie right
rather than watching the movie this is
why all that's so damaging because the
devil's trying to steal that experience
from you absolutely yeah absolutely man
we've got to get young people involved
yeah even more i mean now's the time
yeah so i have to i have to i have to
say the reason i have a picture of an rv
in here because this is actually really
cool so right so reed like this guy
who's just like giving up hope he meets
this and he's blown away he's like who
are these people that knock on my back
door you know that want to sing to me
right that want to share with me
literature they want to like encourage
me he's like he's like what it's like
what church do you guys go to like where
are you guys from you're like i want to
join your church
he's blessed right
but he's like i want to join your church
he's like he's like i got my medical bag
he's like i was special forces he's like
i was a medic and the special forces
like i got a whole medical gear back
it's like put me to work i'm ready to go
to work right so it's like now now
you're in the moment of conversion right
he's ready he's like ready to deploy so
it's like okay well we can't really give
him a chainsaw
needs a day to work that out of his
system right you know but but he's ready
so how do we put so we admit in the
point of distribution the day before
there pulls up this rv right and this is
this is the hand of god right
because
jim ingersoll the guy that's in charge
of all the kids there he comes to me
says brock you need to meet this guy he
has this brand new rv come talk to him
so i get in there and i talk to this guy
the rv and he's like and he's like hey
he's like you know um i just want to uh
his name is earl it's like my name is
earl's like i just want to offer you
guys i've got a brand new rv here god's
blessed me and and he's like i can sleep
eight people in here i can i can give
showers if people need showers he's like
the rv is like at your disposal how can
you guys use it and i'm thinking i don't
even know what to do with them
we're in a disaster like what do you do
with an rv you know i mean that's
awesome but i don't have use for it i'll
keep your number yeah
so he gives me his number and he's just
he's handing me he's begging he's like
it's like i want to be involved i want
to be involved i want to be involved
and um
and so he he ends up
i said sure come on out to where we're
working in the zest field somebody here
needs a shower sure enough one of the
head ladies there the hoa she was like
no shower for four or five days when i
told her there was a shower available
for her in this rv broke down in tears
yeah
so he comes and sets up he's giving
showers he's you know he's he's doing
his thing right no problem
well come to find out earl works with
the department of veteran affairs
uh as a physician's assistant was a
veteran himself in the air force and a
medic a flight medic for a long time and
so when he hears the story about reed
he's like
i've got it i've got it he's like i'm
going to run a little medical clinic
here i'm going to patch up people's
little splinters and wounds if they need
stitches i'll stitch them up like i can
do all that stuff right out of my rv
he's like send read my way he can work
with me the whole day right so now so
now reed has an outlet right so now reed
is immediately put to work and here he
is actually working next to our boy who
got up off the couch with his you know
video game controller and and it's just
you can see the gears are just turning
his mind he's like what in the world
like how did all this come together
right
and and you can see how god is just
lovingly orchestrating the entire
operation from start defense yeah
absolutely and i don't know if you're
going to get to this but wasn't it
wasn't reed a fan of the sport yeah that
our egg uh soft agnostic was
this stuff is crazy brother like you
can't yeah wait what wait what yeah we
gotta go back so
so not only does riga's tree ripped out
and everything else like that but the
individual that comes to clear his
driveway he's been a fan of yeah
yeah i mean we serve a guy that's
awesome who is that
cognizant that's awesome knowing how to
just gently say i love you i'm mindful
of you
and also has a little sense of humor
yeah you know what i mean like you watch
this yeah you think i've forgotten about
you no way
i'm gonna get that clear to get you some
prayer going on get you a song and
you're going to meet somebody you're
going to want to meet today you know in
the midst of i mean talk about
encouraging you and giving you hope
right um
there was a um
you know the the candle factory right
this is all this was news everyone
effectively this is
mayfield right so this is kind of like
downtown mainfield right i mean and it's
it's obliterated brother like i don't
even
words can't even put even the pictures
right don't even do it when you're
standing there
you're like life this there could be no
life here that's that was my impression
like there's life here 200 people on
that site when they got hit direct hit
yeah how many lost their lives i don't
know i don't know if they've tallied it
fully up yet yeah
80 i think we're missing at least yeah
and there were a few we met a few
different people from the candle factory
a few stories stand out but one that we
heard which was so powerful
um
a spanish-speaking brother we met
he's there uh he's at work trying to get
let go from his job so he released from
his job so he can go check his wife who
called him from her cell phone that was
under debris and rubble at the candle
factory
okay this is like what
he zooms over there as fast as he can he
gets there he starts to search for as
long as he could as long as he could
until he got tired
and he sits down like on a beam and he
prays brother i think he's like four
children
he's going lord i need this woman hmm
i need this woman lord i cannot
go on wow without this woman
and no sooner than he prays and he lifts
his head and someone is calling his
attention hey man over here
there are people there's people over
here oh wow so he goes over they
acknowledge agree that okay they're
hearing people under this debris in
rubble and he starts to get to work
moving the debris and then he runs into
these like metal structures or beams
that he can't like move or do anything
with and he says then he's handed some
tulle and he starts using his tool and
it's cutting through the debris oh wow
so he cuts through the debris starts to
pull people out i think there was a
person or two that lost their lives
unfortunately do you know that man
pulled his wife out of there
wow in the individual advice knew the
story correctly that had done all this
for him was nowhere to be found oh wow
wow
wow over here yeah right yeah gives you
chills
when you see like when you see god
working come on so i just feel like yeah
take that story in the context of you
potentially wanting to blame god for the
tornado right yeah it doesn't match up
no no right it doesn't match up like
this man
over like he look he gave up hope
brother it looks like
yeah what do you look like somebody
she called um so he they got her out she
was uh she was at the hospital
um i think someone from our team had
gone over to speak to us here give him
some more help and assistance
and
what
a testimony man just have what an answer
to prayer that he threw himself on the
mercies of god
and
you know i'm gonna say it man god sent
an angel brother
sent an angel let's just call it what it
is yeah sent an angel to help this man
find his wife i mean listen he could
have gone to any pile right right right
right any
mound of debris right he could have been
there but it was this map
right here wow
you have to realize you have to realize
like when the scripture says that god is
not willing that is any should perish
all right but that all should come to
everlasting life like like he is in it
to win it every soul every person like
he is not willing to lose a single soul
if he can if he can do something if it
means he sends his angel or he
dispatches this group of people or he
uses this situation or he uses whatever
you know i mean you name it god is in it
to reach people and man like um talking
about this team here just in closing we
got this email in our deal from this is
from earl okay so this is the
physician's assistant that was working
with reed you know the special forces
guy that was giving up hope
and he writes us this message okay
because he can't get a hold of us it's
kind of hard to get a hold of us
we're kind of a janky you know so you
send us an email maybe we'll get back to
you you know so he sends an email on our
website right and he's and he says he
says within a 24-hour period i met brock
in mayfield kentucky then michael
maraschina and cambridge shores another
team member was ours then reed metcalf
he's the army special forces medic on
the brink of suicide
and then i met
this
famous guy right okay the sports guy
i've been ever since i've been talking
with doug our pilot who flew from who
flew michael to kentucky all of these
people were pieces of a puzzle thrown
down quickly precisely lovingly together
by the creator of our universe to save
reed's life and soul
i witnessed these men plus god opened so
many doors on so many levels so quickly
and lovingly it defies any explanation
except
god's appointed people wow well then i
want to ride on your shirt tails i'll
bring my gift from god my motor home my
skill set as a physician assistant my
past experience working with veterans my
love of god and people with me can i
please join you please wow
right you know is it
to have his resource right used by your
team right i mean this is this is the
power in the hand of god and this is
what excites us every time we do this is
because we see god growing an army you
know to give god glory in these days in
which we live where we're seeing these
things happen we're seeing the world
fall apart
and as we give people context for why
this is happening we give people hope
hope in a god that has not forgotten
them has not abandoned them they will
not leave them nor forsake them yes
right yes and that's what you see and
it's like god will use anybody right
it's like even in this picture like from
varied experience whether it be previous
military experience whether you've got
like espn
experience whether you've got hollywood
experience where you mean like god's
calling together an army even the
gentleman that took these pictures
i mean has a gift that god has given him
to just go out there and photograph
what's going on so that these stories
can be told to a greater audience and
they can be blessed by some of that
you guys what you're doing is you're
essentially being angels
because what is an angel a messenger
and what you're doing is bringing people
a message of hope i think it's just
absolutely beautiful beautiful awesome i
mean
tell our audience brock
where can people get involved with your
ministry if you guys out there now i got
an opportunity to go one time on on
their trips and uh it was it was a
blessing i have
yet to go on another one i wanna i wanna
you know someday experience some of
these miraculous things that these guys
are always talking about i mean we can
stay here all day long and hear story
after story about how god works but if
you guys are interested in linking up
with him i don't care what you do for a
living you're an accountant you're a
button pusher you're a factory worker
you can be useful in the cause of god
just like these gentlemen have have said
this so how can people get a hold of you
if you go to if you go to
gideonrescue.org
we have a website there you can you can
submit a little form on there that gives
us a message um and the biggest thing is
just start the conversation with us i
mean we'll we'll get back to you i
promise at some point i check the email
when i can and then we'll you know
message you talk to you um we can
exchange phone numbers and interest and
really i mean just we've actually
stopped recruiting like we used to do
that we used to kind of recruit pretty
heavily but we we found out that god
knows the heart
and we can't read that so really the
biggest actual things we i know it's
kind of counterintuitive we actually
don't spend a lot of time recruiting for
people because we say lord we want you
to bring us the right hands at the right
time yeah even though you're sitting on
the couch playing video games so so so
if god is laying it on your heart now
that you have a conviction you're like
man i got to be a part of this then man
contact us reach out like if if you're
moved by
god's spirit you'll figure out a way to
get a hold of us even if we're hard to
get a hold of amen
tell me uh a little bit about your
preaching where can people get a hold of
some of your material yeah so right now
um my handle is uh go stand and preach
on tick tock youtube kind of starting
from the ground up nice um you can find
some of my sermons which i'm moving over
to my youtube channel um at the hayden
lake seventh avenue church um i've
preached there quite a bit um other than
that yeah go stand and preach that's
where you can find me i love it i love
it look these guys up check out their
ministries and uh we hope you guys were
blessed by today's talk uh i know i
certainly can sit here for hours and
hours and hours and hear amazing stories
of what god is doing he is working
mightily in the end of these days to win
souls and he is using any willing heart
that is able to go out there and so if
that's your desire i hope and pray that
you will just
ask god where do you want me to go
here's my two hands put me to work and i
guarantee you you will not be sorry god
will give you something to do
and it could easily bless somebody in a
time of crisis like this if you're going
through a crisis yourself uh
you know do you have any advice for for
people you coming from this what would
you tell our audience about
how to deal with this
first and foremost lean on god
speak to him like a friend
you know laugh cry yell
shout whatever you have to do
take care of your mind take the time to
sit be alone get exercise run
good fresh air good good meals a lot of
times doesn't happen when you're so just
bound up with grief and strife get
around people that love you
and that care for you i mean those are
just some of the few of the practical
things you can do
um but be open to allow yourself to go
through probably a range of emotions and
to grieve
you know and
hopefully you can get to a place where
you can take that
lost energy important to someone else
because there are tons of people that
are hurting
and they're looking for an opportunity
to connect with somebody else so you can
be a source of help to lead somebody to
christ in just that for sure and
interestingly enough by doing that your
healing you know takes place in that too
praise god
well thank you guys for watching and uh
we'll leave the links in the description
below how you can get a hold of these
two guys in their ministries but thank
you for watching and we'll catch you
next week
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
so
you